What which which which dialect of Fortran? Well, I had been taught what five obviously at Waterloo. Sorry, wait, pause what five? What's what? Well, what five is obviously what comes after what four which is short for Waterloo Fortran. It's pretty good. Oh, really? Yes. welcome to adsp the podcast episode 92 recorded on august 15th 2022 my name is connor today with my co-host bryce we interview the one and only kate gregory anyways today as promised we have the esteemed Kate Gregory. We are definitely going to talk about, do a little CPP North retro and maybe talk a little bit about carbon because obviously you're involved there. But in preparation for this podcast, I went back and listened to CPP Cast episode 30, which has a special place in my heart because it's basically... You prepared for this podcast?
到底、到底、到底是哪一种方言的 Fortran？嗯，我显然是在滑铁卢大学学过 What5。对不起，等等，暂停，What Five？What 是什么？嗯，What Five 显然是紧接着 What Four 之后的，它是 Waterloo Fortran（滑铁卢 Fortran）的简称。挺不错的。哦，真的吗？是的。欢迎收看第 92 期 adsp 播客，录制于 2022 年 8 月 15 日。我的名字是康纳（Connor），今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们采访了独一无二的凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）。无论如何，今天正如承诺的那样，我们请到了尊敬的凯特·格雷戈里。我们绝对会聊聊，做一点 CPP North 回顾，也许还会聊一点 Carbon，因为显然你参与其中。但在为这个播客做准备时，我回去听了 CppCast 第 30 期，它在我心中占据着特殊的位置，因为它基本上……你为这个播客做准备了？
Of course. Unlike you, Bryce, I prepare for these podcasts because I love these podcasts. And Kate has had a big influence on my career. Episode 30 of CppCast, I basically stole the title from my algorithm intuition talk that later on became like a trilogy from that episode when you were talking about algorithms and how we needed to have intuition for algorithms. And I wanted to see how much of an introduction they gave you because they read your bio. And then in that episode, you mentioned briefly that before you came to C++, you did a little bit of Fortran and PL1.
当然。不像你，布莱斯，我为这些播客做准备，因为我热爱这些播客。凯特对我的职业生涯产生了很大的影响。CppCast 的第 30 期，我基本上是从我的“算法直觉”演讲中偷了那个标题，后来那个演讲从那一期节目开始演变成了一个三部曲，当时你在谈论算法以及我们需要对算法有直觉。我想看看他们给你的介绍有多少，因为他们宣读了你的个人简介。然后在那期节目中，你简短地提到在来到 C++ 之前，你做过一点 Fortran 和 PL1。
That's my sandwich. Okay, unimportant. Bryce, unimportant. I'm in the middle of making a point here. And Rob mentioned that basically part of the reason he started CppCast is from listening to you as a guest on.NET Rocks, which is a podcast actually that I had until today never listened to because I don't do anything in.NET Rocks, which is a podcast actually that I had until today never listened to because I don't do anything in.NET.
那是我的三明治。好吧，不重要。布莱斯，不重要。我这里正说到点子上。罗布（Rob）提到，他创办 CppCast 的部分原因基本上是因为听了你作为嘉宾上 .NET Rocks 的节目，其实这是一个我直到今天之前从未听过的播客，因为我不做任何 .NET 相关的…….NET Rocks，其实这是一个我直到今天之前从未听过的播客，因为我不做任何 .NET 相关的事情。
And I also like to go back and listen to all of the episodes of a podcast I listened to from like episode zero. And there's like thousands of.NET Rocks. Yeah, that's a no, yeah. Yeah. So like I can't really start listening because it would destroy like a year of my podcast listening. What I did though do is go back and what I found,
而且我还喜欢回过头去听我听过的一个播客的所有单集，从第 0 期开始。那里有成千上万期的 .NET Rocks。是的，那可不行，是的。是的。所以，我真的无法开始听，因为那会毁掉我大约一年的播客收听时间。不过我做的是回去找，我发现的，
what I thought was the first one was you going on in 2008. But they were talking for like the first 20 minutes about threading and like two very specific timing libraries and like some.NET stack. And I was like, there's no way this is how they're introducing Kate. Sure enough, it was actually like your fifth appearance. And your first one was on November 8th, 2004. And that was sort of when they did an introduction of you. But it's still, it was not the story of Kate Gregory. And so now I've just rambled on for a bit. Anyone that sort of is in the C++ community and watches talks will know Kate. So she really, she needs no introduction.
我以为的第一期是你 2008 年上的那一期。但他们在前 20 分钟里一直在谈论线程和两个非常特定的计时库以及一些 .NET 栈。当时我想，这绝对不可能是他们介绍凯特的方式。果不其然，那其实大约是你的第五次亮相。你的第一次亮相是在 2004 年 11 月 8 日。那可以说是他们对你进行介绍的时候。但即便如此，那也不是凯特·格雷戈里的故事。所以现在我废话了一通。任何在 C++ 社区并且观看演讲的人都会认识凯特。所以她真的不需要介绍。
I think you've been programming, it says in your bio, from 1979, which is like over 40 years now, which is like a full decade before either Bryce and I were born. So you're really making us look bad in terms of experience. You're a Microsoft MVP. Do you know how many years running you've been?
你的个人简介上写着，我想你从 1979 年就开始编程了，这也就是 40 多年前了，这比布莱斯和我出生整整早了十年。所以在经验方面，你真的让我们相形见绌。你是一位微软 MVP。你知道你连续当了多少年吗？
Because I think it's been year after year after year that you've been a MVP. What is a microsoft mvp so historically uh historically the mvps were people who were very active on compu surf i don't even know what that is what is you can look it up on wikipedia before was an internet, you could dial up to things and you could talk to people by topic area. And CompuServe was, I don't know, like pre-AOL was for the cognoscenti, I guess. And there were forums for Microsoft stuff like, I don't understand this error I'm getting from the compiler. And various volunteer people would answer these questions in addition to paid actual support workers. And Microsoft decided that if they threw a little
因为我觉得你一年又一年、年复一年地担任 MVP。什么是微软 MVP？所以历史上，呃，历史上的 MVP 是那些在 CompuServe 上非常活跃的人。我甚至不知道那是什么，那是什么？你可以在维基百科上查一下，在互联网出现之前，你可以拨号连接到各种东西，你可以按主题与人交流。CompuServe 是，我不知道，就像 AOL 出现前专为高级知识分子准备的，我猜。那里有关于微软产品的论坛，比如，“我搞不懂编译器报的这个错误”。除了带薪的实际支持人员之外，各种志愿者也会回答这些问题。微软决定，如果他们给这些人一点
swag at those folks, they wouldn't need to hire so many support workers. It's very smart, very smart. So that was kind of the origin of the MVP program. And it used to just entirely be your online contributions, you know, like some forum or another. And once the internet comes along, you know, what's your stack overflow reputation or whatever. And then around the turn of the century, they're like, you know, there's other ways for people to contribute. And this person's written a whole bunch of books, and that probably counts. And so then I got to be an MVP, which was fun. And for decades, basically, you've been an mvp then yes so and it sounded if you
小福利（swag），他们就不需要雇佣那么多的支持人员了。非常聪明，非常聪明。所以这就是 MVP 项目的起源。它过去完全取决于你的在线贡献，你知道的，比如这样那样的论坛。一旦互联网出现，你知道的，你的 Stack Overflow 声誉是什么之类的。然后在世纪之交左右，他们想，你知道的，人们还有其他贡献的方式。这个人写了一大堆书，那可能也算数。于是我成了 MVP，这很有趣。基本上几十年来，你一直都是 MVP，是吗？是的，听起来如果你
said 80s you've also not only have you been programming for over a decade longer than either bryce and i've been alive you've been an mvp for longer than we've been alive as well well no i don't think you're i don't think you're 18 connor um i see you said eight uh 18 years not 1980s i see yeah yeah um it was i think it was like early in the turn of the century, but I'm not at home. Or I would take you over to the bookshelf of showing off where I have all the- A bunch of awards.
说 80 年代，你不仅编程时间比布莱斯和我出生还要早十多年，你当 MVP 的时间也比我们出生还要久远。好吧，不，我不认为你是，我不认为你 18 岁，康纳，呃，看，你说的是八，呃，18 年，而不是 20 世纪 80 年代，我明白了，对，对，呃，我想那是世纪之交的早期，但我不在家。否则我会带你去看那个摆满了我的——一堆奖项的书架。
Yeah, they send you stuff. They send me a lot of plexiglass. They're really into like little plexiglass cubes with things engraved in them. And the MVP program sends you you eight and a half by 11 certificate thingamies that you could put on the wall and the stack of them is like six inches thick because they send me one every year and i just put it in front of the one before wow well we will in a future recording uh have you record from home and then i don't know or
是的，他们会寄给你东西。他们寄给我很多有机玻璃（Plexiglas）。他们真的很喜欢刻有东西的小有机玻璃方块。MVP 项目会寄给你八点五乘十一英寸的证书小玩意儿，你可以把它挂在墙上，那一堆证书大约有六英寸厚，因为他们每年都寄给我一个，我只是把它放在前一个的前面。哇，好吧，我们将在未来的录音中，呃，让你在家录音，然后我不知道，或者
maybe we'll get you just to send us a photo at some point. I'll send you a picture of the bookshelf of showing off. But the point about being an MVP is that it's not necessarily Microsoft declaring that you're really smart or you're really knowledgeable. You actually have to be really generous. I mean, if you were generous and stupid and kept giving people bad advice, you probably wouldn't qualify, but it's people who just give information. They help other people. Conference talks and books count. So that's how I get it. But also, you know, answering a million questions on Stack Overflow, whatever. And getting rid of things that are
也许我们会在某个时候让你给我们发张照片。我会给你发一张炫耀书架的照片。但关于成为 MVP 的一点是，这不一定是微软宣告你真的很聪明或你真的很博学。你实际上必须非常慷慨。我的意思是，如果你既慷慨又愚蠢，不断给别人糟糕的建议，你可能就不会合格，但这是关于那些只提供信息的人。他们帮助其他人。会议演讲和书籍都算数。这就是我获得它的方式。但还有，你知道的，在 Stack Overflow 上回答无数问题，诸如此类。并且消除那些阻止
keeping people from using Microsoft products, which in my case would be Visual C++. So yeah, we will have links to, I mean, all of that info. And this is we have that's like just scratching the surface of Kate's bio. You also recently I mean, you've had Pluralsight courses from the past, but you've just released a new one. You recently published a book with Guy Davidson, which there was also a CPP cast episode about on top of that book yeah it's one of the few i mean bryce doesn't read a lot of books and it's one of the few books that bryce has read and has positive things to say about although i haven't heard you say bad things about other books but it's one of the few books that i can recommend yes there there are a lot of very bad c++ books like well it's the reason it's one of the few books that i can recommend is because it's a book that's
人们使用微软产品的障碍，在我的情况下，那就是 Visual C++。所以，是的，我们会附上链接，我的意思是，所有这些信息。这还只是触及了凯特个人简介的表面。你最近还——我的意思是，你过去有过 Pluralsight 课程，但你刚刚发布了一门新课程。你最近和盖伊·戴维森（Guy Davidson）合著了一本书，除此之外，还有一个关于那本书的 CPP cast 节目。是的，这是少数几本——我的意思是，布莱斯不怎么读书，这是布莱斯读过并对之有积极评价的少数几本书之一，虽然我没听过你对其他书说坏话，但这是我能推荐的少数几本之一。是的，有很多非常糟糕的 C++ 书籍，嗯，它之所以是我能推荐的少数几本书之一，是因为它是一本
a collection of like like the chapters are like you know concrete recommendations so it's in some ways like a collection of guidance of specific concrete guidance sort of like effective c++ yes um and uh that i think is something that like is useful to me i'm not somebody that's going to sit down and read like a a programming book normally but something like that that that that style that format like I can I can respect that and that's also something that like I would go and take concrete lessons from that perhaps we chose 30 that we thought would be really applicable to the most people, the most immediately usable. Some of the guidelines are barely guidelines. They're like, try to write readable code.
由一系列……像章节一样是具体的建议构成的书。所以在某些方面，它就像是一本具体、实际指导的指南集合，有点像《Effective C++》。是的，呃，而且我认为这对我来说是有用的东西。我通常不是那种会坐下来阅读编程书的人，但像那种风格、那种格式的东西——我能尊重它，这也是我会去从中汲取具体经验教训的东西，也许我们挑选了 30 个我们认为对最多人、最能立即派上用场的最适用的建议。有些准则几乎不能算是准则。它们就像是，尽量编写可读的代码。
Okay. It's not what you'd call precise, right? And some of them only apply to certain people or only in certain circumstances or what have you. But we sort of went through and found some that we thought were immediately useful. And then their secondary purpose is the whole thing is kind of an ad for the guidelines. Like if you find these 30 are good now that someone sat you down and walked you through them in a lot more detail than what you get online. Maybe you'll be prepared to trust some of the other couple of hundred as well. You know, they're not explained quite the same way, but they are still good advice. We will leave links to the book to all of some. Kate's been on CBP cast three times from episode 30.
好吧。这可算不上精确，对吧？其中一些只适用于特定的人，或者只在特定的情况下适用，诸如此类。但我们大致浏览了一遍，并挑选了一些我们认为能立即派上用场的准则。它们的第二个目的是，整本书有点像是对完整版准则的广告。如果你觉得这 30 条很好，现在有人坐下来带你更详细地过了一遍，而这比你在网上看到的要详细得多。也许你也会准备好去信任另外几百条。你知道，它们的解释方式不完全一样，但它们仍然是很好的建议。我们会留下该书的链接，以及一些链接。凯特从第 30 期开始，已经在 CppCast 上出现过三次了。
I wrote them down to 148 to 238. I think you were on.net rocks like 10 or 11 times from what I could count. And that's just those two podcasts. You've had a prolific career of being interviewed on different podcasts. I will compile a list of all that I can get my hands on. I can't say I've listened to all of them. I've listened to all the CPPcast ones. Your interview on co-recursive as well, slightly a different tone than like super technical,
我把它们记下来了，第 148 期到第 238 期。我想你大概上过 10 或 11 次 .NET Rocks，这是我能数出来的。这还只是这两个播客。你在不同的播客中接受采访，有着硕果累累的职业生涯。我会整理一份我能找到的所有列表。我不能说我都听过。我听过所有 CppCast 的节目。你在 co-recursive 上的采访也很棒，基调略有不同，不像超级技术流，
but an amazing listen that everyone, even feel free to pause this episode and go listen to that one right now and then come back when you're done because that one's fantastic as well um but i think to start before we get to talking about you know maybe we'll talk about your pluralsight course a little bit later and cpp north and carbon let's go back let's tell and i'm not sure maybe you can even um refer listeners to an interview that I have yet to listen to on a different podcast where you tell some of, and maybe the co-recursive is a little bit of that as well, but let's go back to all the way either before Waterloo, which is where I happen to know, I think you went to study. And I had very
但绝对是一次精彩的聆听，每个人——甚至可以随时暂停这一期节目去听那一期，然后再回来，因为那一期也棒极了。嗯，但我想在开始之前，在我们讨论——也许我们稍后会讨论你的 Pluralsight 课程、CPP North 和 Carbon——让我们回顾一下，讲讲……我不确定，也许你甚至可以向听众推荐我在另一个播客上尚未收听的采访，你在那里讲述了一些……也许 co-recursive 里也有一点，但让我们一路回顾到滑铁卢之前，我碰巧知道那是你学习的地方。而且我当时非常
fun when I was listening to the first time you were on.NET Rocks, which I think was episode 88 in 2004. You actually mentioned APL. You probably have zero recollection of that. But I always love, even if it's just a short mention, and I'll let listeners go and discover what you said about it. It was just a small mention. And I think at Waterloo, that was probably how you were exposed to it
有趣的是，当我听你第一次上 .NET Rocks 时，那好像是 2004 年的第 88 期。你实际上提到了 APL。你可能对此毫无记忆了。但我总是很喜欢，哪怕只是简短的提及，我也会让听众自己去发现你对它说了什么。那只是一次小小的提及。我想在滑铁卢，这大概就是你接触到它的方式，
because I do know that at some point they were teaching that. But yeah, tell us how the story, you know, the brief history of Kate Gregory and how you, you know, got into computing. And then, you know, the brief summary of your 40 year, which is probably going to be hard to summarize into, you know. In five minutes. Yeah, that is a challenge. You can have 30 if you want. I did go to Waterloo and I went, originally I was in the faculty of mathematics, which is where they teach computer science. And I was in a brand new program they just made, which was computer science with an engineering
因为我确实知道他们在某个时候教过那个。但是，是的，给我们讲讲这个故事，你知道的，凯特·格雷戈里的简短历史，以及你是如何进入计算机领域的。然后，你知道的，你 40 年生涯的简短总结，这可能很难总结成，你知道的。五分钟。是的，那是一个挑战。如果你愿意，你可以用 30 分钟。我确实去了滑铁卢大学，我最初在数学系，那是他们教授计算机科学的地方。我加入了一个他们刚刚开设的全新项目，即计算机科学加工程
minor. So I was minoring in chem-eng. And the program wasn't put together right. The classes you had to take from chemistry or from engineering conflicted with courses you had to take from math. Like, they just hadn't thought it through. So it was very, very difficult, big struggle for me. And I did that for a year.
辅修。所以我辅修了化学工程。那个项目设置得不对。你必须从化学或工程学选修的课程与你必须从数学选修的课程冲突了。就像，他们根本没有考虑周全。所以对我来说非常非常困难，是一场巨大的挣扎。我学了一年。
And there was other things in my life that were difficult at the time. And I'm like, I don't want to be in this program anymore. So I transferred into engineering. And I ended up graduating from chemical engineering. So I just had a year and a bit of officially computer science-y stuff. But I met all these people in the Faculty of Mathematics who were dear friends of mine, one of whom I ended up marrying. And so I sort of stayed connected into that world while I was taking engineering. And Waterloo is co-op, for those who don't know. And engineering is 100% co-op. So you go to school
那时我的生活中还有其他困难的事情。我想：我不想再学这个项目了。所以我转到了工程系。最终我从化学工程专业毕业了。所以我实际上只有一年多的时间接触官方的计算机科学相关内容。但在数学系，我遇到了所有这些成为我挚友的人，其中一个人最终成为了我的丈夫。因此，在攻读工程学的同时，我某种程度上仍然与那个世界保持着联系。对于那些不知道的人来说，滑铁卢大学是合作教育（co-op）模式。工程系是 100% 的合作教育。所以你上学四个月，然后工作四个月，接着上学四个月，再工作四个月。在工作中，他们教你一些东西，比如，哦，我们需要一个能做这个、能做那个的人。所以，在某个时候，有人教我用 Fortran 编程。字面意思上，我参与编写的一些程序是用打孔卡片完成的。哪种方言的 Fortran？嗯，我显然在滑铁卢学过 What5。抱歉，等等，暂停。What Five？什么是 What Five？嗯，What Five 显然是紧接着 What Four 之后的，它是 Waterloo Fortran（滑铁卢 Fortran）的简称。
for four months, then you work for four months, then you go to school for four months, then you work for four months. And at work, they teach you stuff like, oh, we need someone who can do this and who can do that. And so at some point, somebody taught me how to program in Fortran. Literally, some of the programs I worked on were in cards. Which dialect of Fortran? Well, I had been taught What5, obviously, at Waterloo. Sorry, wait, pause. What Five? What's What Five? Well, What Five is obviously what comes after What Four, which is short for Waterloo Fortran.
然后工作四个月，接着上学四个月，再工作四个月。在工作中，他们会教你一些东西，比如，我们需要一个会做这个、会做那个的人。所以在某个时候，有人教我用Fortran编程。实际上，我参与的一些程序是用打孔卡片编写的。哪种Fortran方言？嗯，我当然是在滑铁卢学过Wat5。等等，暂停。Wat 5？Wat 5是什么？嗯，Wat 5显然是Wat 4的后续版本，Wat 4是Waterloo Fortran的简称。
It's pretty good. Oh, really? Yes. I'm going to have to dig some links up for that. What Five is what comes after What Four, which is Waterloo Fortran. So is that W-A-T-F-O-R? Yes. Yes.
挺不错的。哦，真的吗？是的。我得去挖一些相关的链接。What Five 是在 What Four 之后推出的，也就是 Waterloo Fortran。所以那是 W-A-T-F-O-R 吗？是的。是的。
And then there was what5 and then there was what5s, which was structured. Right? So that you're you had the ends of ifs and you had loops and things rather than just all go-tos. It's a big deal. I just get interview questions. Explain what makes a program structured. Really?
然后有了 what5，接着是 what5s，那是结构化的。对吧？这样你的 if 语句有结尾，你有循环之类的，而不仅仅是所有的 goto。这可是个大事件。我只拿到过面试题：解释一下是什么让程序变得结构化。真的吗？
I had never heard of this before. I mean, obviously I heard of Fortran, but not that Waterloo had their own variants of it. Yeah. So at some point I learned Fortran along the way, like partly at school and partly on work terms. And by the time I got to third or fourth year in engineering, they just assumed that somebody knew how to program. So they'd like, here's a group assignment. You need to take these measurements, write this program, draw this graph, blah, blah, blah, divide it up amongst yourselves.
我以前从没听说过这个。我的意思是，我显然听说过 Fortran，但不知道滑铁卢有他们自己的变体。是的。所以在某个时候，我在成长过程中学会了 Fortran，一部分是在学校，一部分是在工作期间。到了工程系三年级或四年级时，他们就直接假设某人懂编程。所以他们会说：这是一个小组作业。你们需要进行这些测量，编写这个程序，画这张图，等等等等，你们自己分工。
And I was always the only one who knew how program so i did all the programming and then i started ending up doing it on work terms and um and then it was sort of most of what i was doing was programming which is fine i was good at it what is that like back like because that's pre-internet right so there's no like my concept so how did how did you how did you google no no there's no google answers that's what i'm saying my concept of programming and like learning things doesn't exist it's not possible back then so what is it just reading texts and going to the library? It's a lot of books. Yeah, it's like multiple books open on your desk at once. It's talking to other humans in the building. It's, I think there was some CompuServe action.
而我总是唯一一个懂编程的人，所以我包办了所有的编程工作。然后我开始在工作期间做这个，呃，然后基本上我做的大部分事情都是编程，这挺好的，我很擅长这个。那在当时是什么感觉？因为那是互联网出现之前的时代，对吧？所以没有像我的概念那样……所以你是怎么做的？你是怎么在没有 Google 的情况下学习的？不，不，没有 Google，没有答案，这就是我想说的。我关于编程和学习新知识的概念在当时根本不存在，这是不可能的。所以当时是靠阅读课本并去图书馆吗？主要是很多书。是的，就像桌上同时翻开好几本书。是和楼里的其他人类交流。是的，我想当时有一些 CompuServe 的操作。
I can't remember exactly when CompuServe started. Someone's going to have to go on Wikipedia and look it up. But that idea of reaching out to strangers, we know was super, super impressive the moment it started. And there was, there was Usenet newsgroups. I remember that, um, whole pile of, uh, computing related, uh, newsgroups. And stuff just took a lot longer, you know, cause you didn't know how to do it. So, you know, you keep trying until it would finally work kind of thing. Yeah. And then after I'd been working for two years, I'd always intended to go back to grad school and be a prof.
我不记得 CompuServe 具体是什么时候开始的了。总得有人去维基百科查一下。但那种向陌生人求助的想法，我们知道从它出现的那一刻起就超级超级震撼。而且还有，还有 Usenet 新闻组。我记得，呃，一整堆，呃，计算相关的新闻组。而且事情要花很长时间，你知道的，因为你不知道怎么做，所以，你知道的，你会一直尝试，直到它最终能够运行。是的。在我工作了两年之后，我一直打算重返研究生院当一名教授。
Both my parents are profs. I figured that would be a good thing to do. And there was a downturn in the industry and they wanted to, they didn't want to lay people off. I was working at Time for Imperial Oil, which is SO in Canada. And they'd never laid anybody off ever. And they didn't want to start. So they bribed you with money to go away on your own volition. Oh, what do they call that?
我的父母都是教授。我觉得那会是一件不错的事情。当时行业正处于低谷，他们不想裁员。我当时在为帝国石油公司（Imperial Oil）工作，也就是加拿大的 SO。他们从来没有裁过任何人。他们不想开这个先例。所以他们用钱贿赂你，让你自愿离开。哦，他们管那叫什么？
They call buyouts? I can't remember. Yeah. So they offered me, I forget if it was three or four months gross salary. So if you think about how long it would take you to save three or four months of your gross, it's a lot of money. And what's more, it could go into a retirement savings plan because it was considered a retirement allowance. And I didn't have to pay taxes on it.
他们管这叫买断工龄（buyouts）吗？我记不清了。是的。所以他们给了我三个月还是四个月的税前薪水，我记不清了。所以如果你想想攒下三四个月的税前收入需要多长时间，那是一大笔钱。更重要的是，这笔钱可以存入退休储蓄计划，因为它被视为退休津贴。而且我不需要为此纳税。
So I did that. And I went to do a master's at U of T. And I was modeling the way your blood coagulates. And they said, this is a really juicy program problem that you've got here. And we think it's actually more of a PhD problem. So why don't you just switch to this joint master's PhD program, which was considered to be a feather in my cap to qualify for. So I did that small pause while i had my first kid and uh and then i got my phd from from modeling blood coagulation which was fun but i learned that i did not want to be a prof because uh my parents were profs in the late 60s and the 70s and uh in the 90s uh the life they
所以我照做了。我去多伦多大学（U of T）攻读硕士学位。当时我在对血液凝固的方式进行建模。他们说：你这里有一个非常诱人的程序问题，我们认为这其实更像是一个博士课题。所以你为什么不直接转到这个硕博连读项目中呢？这在当时被认为是一项荣誉，有资格加入。所以我做了那个短暂的停顿，期间我生了第一个孩子，呃，然后我获得了血液凝固建模的博士学位，这很有趣。但我了解到我不想当教授，因为，呃，我父母是在 60 年代末和 70 年代当教授的，而在 90 年代，呃，他们曾经生活过的那种生活已经不再提供给教授了。一切都是“不发表就出局”（publish or parish），呃，我不想要那样。出于好奇，你的……因为我认为你是第二个父母都是教授的嘉宾。戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）如果我没记错的话，他上节目时也有两个不同的……或者说很明显父母双方都是教授。你的父母教什么？是这个引导你走向数学工程的吗？是的，他们一开始是学物理的。我妈妈最后从事的是材料科学。她了解了大量关于电子显微镜之类的内容。
had lived was not on offer to profs it's all publisher parish and uh i didn't want that what did your uh just out of curiosity because i think you are now the second guest that had two parents as professors dave abrahams if i'm not mistaken when he was on had two different um or had two parents obviously that were both professors what did your parents teach was it is that what sort of led you down the mathematical engineering? Yeah, they started out in physics. And my mom ended up in material science. She learned an awful lot about electron microscopy and stuff like that.
曾经的生活并不是教授们的选择，那全都是“不发表就出局”，而我并不想要那样。出于好奇，你的父母——因为我认为你是第二位父母都是教授的嘉宾，如果我没记错的话，戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）上节目时，他的父母显然也都是教授——你的父母教什么科目？是这引导你走向了数理工程吗？是的，他们起初是学物理的。我妈妈最后从事的是材料科学。她对电子显微镜之类的内容了解得非常深入。
And she ended up in material science and then at Spar Aerospace eventually. That's where she retired from. And my dad was an electrical engineer, and he was one of the early profs at the University of Waterloo, which is why I was going there, because I was only 16 in first year, so I wasn't allowed to go anywhere weird or far away. 16? Yeah. Wow. Does that mean you skipped a year? Because 17 is usually the youngest.
她最终从事了材料科学，然后最终加入了加拿大加航空航天公司（Spar Aerospace）。那是她退休的地方。我爸爸是一名电气工程师，他是滑铁卢大学早期的教授之一，这也是为什么我去那里上学，因为我上大一的时候才 16 岁，所以我不能去任何奇怪或遥远的地方。16岁？是的。哇。那意味着你跳级了吗？因为 17 岁通常是最小的年龄。
Yeah, so... Like if you do things normally. I started in England, so I should have been a little bit younger. And then, I don't know, there was just some sort of bullying on my parents' part to get me into the highest possible grade. So I do remember I was eight and they were trying to get me to go into grade five. And in some sort of flourish that would prove I didn't belong in grade five, someone pulled out a grade five book and started asking me questions out of the back of it. It was a math book and I aced them all and they went, okay, fine. Even if it had been a
是的，所以……就像如果你按部就班地做的话。我是在英国开始上学的，所以我应该会更年轻一点。然后，我不知道，我父母做了一些类似施压的事情，让我进入尽可能高的年级。我确实记得我八岁时，他们试图让我上五年级。在一场某种程度上能证明我不属于五年级的展示中，有人拿出一本五年级课本，开始问我后面的问题。那是一本数学书，我全部答对了，然后他们说，好吧，行。即使它是一本
history or geography or, I don't know, sewing book or something, they would have probably, you know, put me back into kindergarten, but they decided it was brilliant because I could answer their math questions. Wow. Yeah. So, but, you know, I had this image of a prof sort of working at home a lot of the time and making your own hours and traveling all over the world to conferences and solving important problems and teaching people. And none of that is actually what you do the first 10 or so years after you earn your Ph.D. But what you just described is exactly what you do now. Exactly. Exactly. I just like, fine, I'm not going to have that label, but I'm going to have, you know, that life. And that is pretty much what I've what I've managed to get to. So it's fun. And so when you decided at that point, after you finished your PhD,
历史书、地理书，或者，我不知道，缝纫书之类的，他们大概也会把我降级到幼儿园，但他们决定这太棒了，因为我能回答他们的数学问题。哇。是的，所以，但是，你知道，我脑子里有这样一种形象：教授大部分时间都在家里工作，自己安排时间，为了会议全世界到处跑，解决重要问题并教导人们。但实际上，在你获得博士学位后的前十年左右，你所做的根本不是这些。但你刚刚描述的恰恰就是你现在所做的事。完全正确。完全正确。我只是想，好吧，我不要那个头衔，但我会拥有那种生活。这基本上就是我所达到的状态，所以这很有趣。所以当你在那个时候决定，在完成博士学位之后，
and you didn't want to be a prof, was it straight back to writing 4chan programs? Or how do you get from there to being, you know, a C++ uber professional and giving talks and international keynotes and whatnot? So I did actually learn C++ during the PhD. I needed to do some numerical solving of multiple partial differential equations that represented the blood coagulation stuff. And what I was trying to do was beyond
并且不想当教授时，是直接回去编写 Fortran 程序吗？还是你是怎么从那里变成一个 C++ 超级专业人士，去进行演讲、国际主题演讲以及诸如此类的活动的？我实际上是在攻读博士学位期间学会 C++ 的。我需要对代表血液凝固机制的多个偏微分方程进行数值求解。而我当时试图做的事情已经超出了
what MATLAB and Maple could do. So I had to write some stuff on my own. equations that represented the blood coagulation stuff. And what I was trying to do was beyond what MATLAB and Maple could do. So I had to write some stuff on my own. And C++ was a better choice, you know, than the other languages that were available to me. So I learned it. And I wrote some stuff, which wasn't bad. And one of my examiners could even read C++. The one who asked for the code couldn't, but the other one could and told me that it was good. And then we had started a consulting firm while I was a student to supplement grad student money, which is quite in need of supplement, let's say that. Yes. To say you get paid while doing your graduate studies is technically true. To say you get paid a living wage is a whole other.
MATLAB 和 Maple 所能做到的范围。所以我必须自己写一些东西。代表血液凝固机制的方程。而我当时试图做的事情已经超出了 MATLAB 和 Maple 所能做到的范围。所以我必须自己写一些东西。而且与当时可用的其他语言相比，C++ 是一个更好的选择，你知道的。所以我学会了它。我写了一些东西，还算不错。我的主考官之一甚至能读懂 C++。那个要求看代码的考官看不懂，但另一个考官看得懂，并告诉我写得很好。然后，在我还是个学生的时候，我们创办了一家咨询公司，用来补贴研究生那点急需补贴的资金——咱们这么说吧。是的。要说你在攻读研究生期间能拿到薪水，技术上来说是真的。但要说你拿的是一份维持生计的薪水，那就是完全另一回事了。
A whole other problem, yes. So we were doing some bits and pieces of contract programming in whatever languages people wanted some stuff done in. And then when I graduated, I thought, well, I'll just keep doing that. So we had some programming contracts and some training contracts. It's interesting that you were allowed to do that because at least at the school that I went to and worked at, LSU, the graduate students were not allowed to work anywhere else. Yes. So there was some rules about how many hours you could work and including as a TA or whatever. And they would really prefer that you put all your time and effort into TA. And the part that I found interesting was when they told me that, you know, on paper, the reason is they don't want to like a work year. They want you to focus on your studies.
完全是另一个问题，是的。所以我们当时在接一些合同编程的零活，用人们希望实现某些功能的不同语言。然后当我毕业时，我想，好吧，我会继续做这个。所以我们有一些编程合同和培训合同。有趣的是，你居然被允许这样做，因为至少在我上学和工作过的学校，路易斯安那州立大学（LSU），研究生是不被允许在任何其他地方工作的。是的。所以有一些关于你可以工作多少小时的规则，包括作为助教（TA）或其他什么。他们其实更希望你把所有的时间和精力都投入到助教工作中。我觉得有趣的部分是，当他们告诉我，从纸面上看，原因是不希望你——比如工作年限。他们希望你专注于学业。
But the sort of the other explanation I got was, well, they want to motivate you to graduate as quickly as possible because it's good for the school if students finish quickly. Or not quickly, but it's good for the school if graduate students finish on time. And so if you're living a cushy life, you might drag on your PhD a little bit. No, they want you to be motivated, itching to get out of there. Yes, yeah, for sure. I had better motivation than that, which is that I had one child while I was doing my program, but I was pretty sure I couldn't have two. So during my final dissertation, I like to tell people this, I had a prenatal vitamin in my pocket. And I would like put my hand in my pocket and feel this prenatal vitamin in my pocket and go like. That's motivation.
但我得到的另一种解释是，嗯，他们希望激励你尽快毕业，因为学生快点毕业对学校有利。或者说，如果研究生能按时毕业，对学校是有利的。所以如果你过着舒适的生活，你可能会把博士学位稍微拖延一下。不，他们希望你受到激励，急着离开那里。是的，确实如此。我有比这更好的动力，那就是我在读博期间生了一个孩子，但我很确定我不能生两个。所以在我的最终论文答辩期间，我喜欢跟人讲这个，我的口袋里装着一粒产前维生素。我会把手伸进口袋，摸摸口袋里的产前维生素，然后想……这就是动力。
Exactly. I'm going to pass this thing and get out of here and have another kid. Wow, that's great. That's awesome. How to motivate yourself to get done. So I wasn't crazy enough to conceive before my final defense, but I was taking them for three months getting ready to. It was good to be connected to a bigger part of the world than just what was going on in that one little room. Wow. And then so is that consulting firm that you started the consulting firm that you have to today basically yes wow so it's been smaller and it's been bigger i think i think we peaked at 11 people um which is actually probably a really awkward size probably we decided to get
没错。我要通过这个答辩，离开这里，再生另一个孩子。哇，太棒了。太棒了。如何激励自己完成学业。所以我没有疯狂到在最终答辩前怀孕，但我为了准备怀孕已经吃了三个月了。能与比那个小房间里发生的事情更广阔的世界保持联系，感觉真好。哇。然后，你当时创办的那家咨询公司就是你至今仍在经营的咨询公司吗？基本上是的，哇。所以它有时规模较小，有时规模较大。我想我们达到过 11 人的顶峰，呃，这其实可能是一个非常尴尬的规模。大概我们决定
smaller rather than trying to get up on to something like 50 where someone else could do the practice management um Because I found that with that many people, I spent a lot of time managing people, which I'm not super great at, selling, managing clients, talking to clients, because if you let developers talk to clients, that doesn't go well. You go like, I know how I'll have more time. I'll just let the developers talk to the clients and I'll just cash the checks. That does not. Yeah. Business analysts is a role for a reason.
缩小规模，而不是试图扩大到像 50 人那样，让其他人来管理业务运营，因为我发现带着那么多人，我花了很多时间管理人，而我在这方面并不是超级擅长。销售、管理客户、与客户交谈，因为如果你让开发人员跟客户交流，事情往往不会顺利。你会想：我知道怎么能有更多时间了。我只要让开发人员和客户交谈，然后我只管兑现支票就行了。这行不通。是的。业务分析师（Business analyst）这个角色存在是有原因的。
They perform a crucial role in the communicating between end users and not that they're not all developers. We shouldn't paint with a single brush. There are many folks I'm sure that are great at interfacing, but know, we shouldn't paint with a single brush. There are many folks, I'm sure that are great, you know, at interfacing, but definitely, yes, there are different folks with different strengths, let's say. Right. Well, a lot of my issue was my people were very generous. So, so people would say, well, I love it, but you know, could this button be blue, which obviously that button can be blue. That's no big deal. And then they'd say,
他们在最终用户之间发挥着至关重要的沟通作用，并不是说他们都不是开发人员。我们不应该一概而论。我确信有许多人非常擅长对接，但是，你知道，我们不应该一概而论。有许多人，我确信他们非常擅长对接，但绝对地，是的，不同的人有不同的优势，比方说。好吧，我的很多问题在于我的员工都太慷慨了。所以，人们会说，嗯，我很喜欢它，但你知道，这个按钮能变成蓝色吗？显然那个按钮可以变成蓝色。那不是什么大不了的事。然后他们会说，
it'd be super cool if there was another column here that showed the something or another date. And you know, I should be able to sort, shouldn't I be able to sort by all of these? I don't think, I don't know if I put it in the spec, but I really think like we should be able to sort by all of these. And my people, you know, they wanted to help. They wanted to solve the problem. They wanted to create wonderful, useful software. So they would do all those things. And eventually, you know, we had to say, we're just going to do what we said we would do. And then if they want us to do more things now that they've seen it, then we can charge them for that. I think this is a common problem across the industry that folks who are purely on the engineering side often think solely about the solution that makes the most technical sense. Yeah. Not necessarily about the thing that makes
如果这里能多一列显示某某日期的东西，那就太酷了。而且你知道的，我应该能够排序，难道我不应该对所有这些进行排序吗？我不认为，我不知道我有没有把它写进规格说明书里，但我真的觉得，我们应该能够对所有这些进行排序。而我的员工，你知道的，他们想要帮忙。他们想要解决问题。他们想要创造出美妙、实用的软件。所以他们会做所有这些事情。最后，你知道的，我们不得不说：我们只会做我们答应过要做的事情。如果他们在看到成品后还想让我们做更多事情，那我们就得向他们收费。我认为这是整个行业的一个普遍问题，纯粹在工程端工作的人往往只考虑技术上最合理的解决方案。是的。而不一定去考虑商业上最合理的方案。
the most business sense. Well, and in fact, when I finally said like, you know, we have to stop doing stuff we didn't agree to do, I expected the clients to be mad. And I thought, my cost is repeat business. Repeat business is really important. But do I really want a repeat of someone who, you know, the thing dragged on for three months or six months or whatever, doing more free stuff? And what really shocked me was the clients were happier. Yes. So when they would ask for stuff they'd never asked for before and the developer would go, oh, sorry, I should have thought of that. Man, that's terrible. I'm sorry. I'll get it to you as quick as I can. And they'd be like, you know, it takes months to get what you asked for. It's
嗯，事实上，当我最终说“我们必须停止做那些我们没有同意去做的事情”时，我以为客户会生气的。我在想，我的成本是回头客。回头客非常重要。但我真的想要一个这样的人的回头客吗？事情被拖了三个月或六个月，或者诸如此类，一直在做更多免费的事情？而真正让我震惊的是，客户反而更高兴了。是的。所以当他们要求一些他们以前从未要求过的事情时，开发人员会说：“哦，对不起，我应该想到这一点的。天哪，太糟糕了。对不起。我尽快为你做好。”他们就会觉得：你知道，拿到你要求的东西要花好几个月。这就像
like pulling teeth, blah, blah. And then once we started saying like, hey, this is what you asked for. If you want an expansion, it's not going to be a lot of work. Let's estimate it for you. We'll do it. They'd be like, oh, I'm getting wonderful service. I got everything I asked for right away. I didn't have to ask twice. So the clients were actually happier while we were making more money. And my people, instead of apologizing, were saying that they had done a good job and that they had done what they had asked for and that they were proud of what they'd done.
拔牙一样，巴拉巴拉。然后一旦我们开始说：“嘿，这就是你要求的。如果你想要扩展，这不会花费太多工作量。我们为你估算一下。我们来做。”他们就会说：“哦，我得到了棒极了的服务。我要求的一切都马上得到了满足。我不用问第二遍。”所以当我们赚更多钱的同时，客户其实更高兴了。而我的员工不再道歉，而是说他们干得很好，他们完成了客户的要求，并且为自己做的事情感到自豪。
And all of that is all good for everyone. Yeah. what they've done and all of that is all good for everyone so yeah i think most uh most project overruns in tech are caused by a lack of a of a clear exit criterion yeah yeah you know you have to you have to know when to say like this is what we plan to do like we've done it like we we may have learned some things while we were doing it but like the original work is done now we can start planning phase two right we can have a phase two we can have a follow-on we can have a sequel whatever but like this part this part's good now yeah yeah we're getting to i mean we're probably gonna uh our listeners know this but uh
所有这些对每个人来说都是好事。是的。他们所做的事情以及所有这一切对每个人来说都是好事。所以，是的，我认为科技行业的大多数项目超支都是由于缺乏清晰的退出标准（exit criterion）。是的，是的。你知道的，你必须知道什么时候该说：这就是我们计划要做的事情——我们已经做完了——我们在做的时候可能学到了一些东西，但最初的工作已经完成了，现在我们可以开始规划第二阶段了。对，我们可以有一个第二阶段，我们可以有一个后续，我们可以有一个续集，无论什么，但像这部分，这部分现在很好了。是的，是的，我们正在接近——我的意思是，我们的听众知道这一点，但
we're probably gonna chop this up into two or three different episodes so this will probably be rounding out the it's got to be three okay it'll be three executive producer bryce says i am in i leave for scotland on friday and then i get back september 9th so we need to stretch this out to let you have more time in the heather. Yeah. All right. So three episodes. This one will round out the introduction to, I mean, probably if you've listened to every episode of, or not episode, but podcast appearance, you might be able to piece together everything that was said here. But hopefully there's some nugget that we got out.
我们可能会把这个剪辑成两到三个不同的单集，所以这大概会结束——这必须是三个，好吧，会是三个。执行制作人布莱斯说：我周五要去苏格兰，然后我于 9 月 9 日回来，所以我们需要把这个拉长，让你有更多时间在石楠花丛中（听）。好吧。所以是三集。这一集将结束对……的介绍，我的意思是，如果你听过每一集，或者说不是每一集，而是播客的每一次亮相，你或许能把这里所说的一切拼凑起来。但希望我们能从中挖出一些干货。
Is there anything you want to round out this sort of over the last, since you've been consulting? I mean, you've gone from speaker to international keynoter, um, to author to Pluralsight course producer. So I don't even know how to describe like what you've evolved. You're just, and also too, I think when we were trying to estimate, that's actually, we should bring that up to see how well the, um, Chandler keynote is done. We were trying to estimate that's actually, we should bring that up to see how well the, um, Chandler keynote is done. We were trying to estimate like, what can we expect for how many views, like when we're estimating on sponsors, you know, what to tell them. And it's like, well, for a first time conference, it's kind of hard, uh, to estimate. But so I went through a few, you know, Chandler and you and like your top talks, like average, like 150,000. So like
有什么你想用来总结自你开始咨询以来的这段经历的吗？我的意思是，你从演讲者变成了国际主旨演讲嘉宾，再到作家、Pluralsight 课程制作人。所以我甚至不知道该如何形容你的演变。你简直就是——而且还有，我想当我们试图估算时——这实际上，我们应该提一下钱德勒（Chandler）的主旨演讲表现如何。我们当时试图估算——这其实，我们应该提一下钱德勒的主旨演讲表现如何。我们当时试图估算：对于浏览量，我们可以期待多少？当我们向赞助商估算时，该告诉他们什么？这有点难，因为对于第一次办的会议来说，很难估算。所以我浏览了一些，你知道的，钱德勒和你，像你们的顶级演讲，平均大约有 15万 的浏览量。所以，
you are very, very like when Kate gives a talk everyone goes and listens whether it's at the conference or after it's been uploaded on YouTube and I'll definitely throw links to some of them I mean everyone know or I would assume most people know the stop teaching C that's probably one of the most that's the big one the most views I would say yeah yeah because it's got kind of a clickbaity title because a lot of people think, oh, no, she's going to dunk on C when that's really not what the talk is about. No, no. The more accurate but less dramatic title is Stop Teaching C When You're Teaching C++. Right.
当凯特发表演讲时，每个人都会去听，无论是在会议上还是在 YouTube 上传之后，我绝对会附上其中一些演讲的链接。我的意思是，每个人都知道——或者我假设大多数人都知道《停止教授 C 语言》（Stop Teaching C）那个演讲，那可能是播放量最高的一个，可以说是浏览量最多的一个，我想是的。是的，因为它的标题有点像诱饵标题，因为很多人认为，哦，不，她要在 C 语言上踩上一脚，而这真的不是那个演讲的内容。不，不。更准确但不那么戏剧化的标题是：当你教 C++ 时，请停止教授 C。对。
Right. Like if you want to learn C, that's fine. It's a good language. It's its own language and there's nothing wrong with it whatsoever. But if you're there to learn C++, like day one being, here's a quick review of C, you know, and day two being, we'll just wrap up our review of C. And then maybe on day three, actually finally get to some C++. What's the point of that? So that's that talk in a nutshell. Thanks for listening. Before we close out, one last announcement. This came up towards the end of our two-hour recording with Kate, and that is that she is going to be in Kongsberg, Norway,
对。如果你想学 C，那没问题。它是一门好语言，它有它自己的语言，而且它本身没有任何问题。但如果你去那里是为了学 C++，而第一天是：这里是 C 的快速复习，你知道的；第二天是：我们将总结对 C 的复习。然后也许到了第三天，终于开始接触一些 C++。那有什么意义呢？所以这就是那个演讲的概括。谢谢收听。在结束之前，还有一个最后的公告。这是在我们与凯特两个小时的录音快结束时提到的，那就是她将前往挪威康斯贝格（Kongsberg），
for the NDC Tech Town that is taking place from the 29th of August to September 1st. So if you're listening to this either on the day that this drops, August 26th, or in the couple days leading up to that, you still might be able to register if you are in the area and able to travel there. So thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即将在8月29日至9月1日举行的NDC Tech Town科技小镇活动。因此，如果您是在本期节目发布的当天（8月26日）或在此之前几天听到这期节目，如果您身处当地且能够前往，或许仍有机会报名参加。感谢您的收听。希望您喜欢本期节目，祝您有美好的一天。本集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。